[Musik]
zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
in manchen bundesländern können sich
jetzt alle die die sich impfen lassen
möchten beim hausarzt oder bei der
hausärztin impfen lassen
vorausgesetzt sie haben einen hausarzt
oder eine hausärztin und vorausgesetzt
sie kriegen einen impftermin und
vorausgesetzt ist es überhaupt genügend
impfstoff da viele voraussetzungen also
die erfüllt sein müssten und darüber
möchten wir heute abend sprechen und vor
allem freuen wir uns auf ihre und eure
erfahrungen die ihr gerade mit dieser
thematik macht und jetzt habe ich schon
wieder angefangen zu duzen ich weiß
einige mögen das nicht ich ziehe das
aber jetzt trotzdem durch es ist nicht
despektierlich gemeint sondern ist es
ganz einfach einfacher also eure fragen
und kommentare bitte an diese e mail
adresse wenn ihr die app nutzt oder wie
immer in die kommentarspalten wenn ihr
social media und youtube nutzt wir sind
nicht alleine in der sendung sondern wir
sprechen gleich mit jemandem der uns
erklären kann wie das funktioniert wenn
man sich für die impfzentren
registrieren lassen möchte über
verschiedene im portal die es gibt und
wir sprechen darüber wie das im moment
in den hausarztpraxen aussieht bei uns
ist dr ulrike kukksi ist hausärztin im
wetteraukreis in hessen schönen guten
abend frau cook und mit dabei ist armin
beck allgemeinmediziner in hofheim im
taunus und vorsitzender des hessischen
hausärzteverbandes und wir sagen dass
gleich dazu das ist tatsächlich zufall
dass wir heute zwei ärzte eine ärztin
einen arzt aus hessen haben das hat sich
einfach so ergeben und hat keinerlei
bedeutung
liebe frau dr cook fangen wir mit ihnen
mal an wir sehen im moment
es gibt viele aus den priorisierung
gruppen 2 und 3 die noch nicht geimpft
sind gleichzeitig macht die politik
vielen menschen aber die hoffnung dass
sie sich alle wenn sie möchten bald
impfen lassen können wie wirkt sich das
auf die praxis aus in der sie tätig sind
also im prinzip wird es wahrscheinlich
an unserem vorgehen erst mal nichts
weiter ändern weil wir zu beginn als wir
mit dem impfen angriff
wir haben sehr lange listen erstellt
haben auf den sich alle haben eintragen
lassen
die sich impfen lassen möchten und die
sind noch nicht abgearbeitet und von
daher wäre es natürlich jetzt unfair
wenn wir jetzt freigegeben würden für
alle die gerne möchten also sehe ich das
verstehen kann dass alle sich impfen
lassen wollen und ich auch nichts
dagegen habe dass die priorisierung
aufgehoben wird ist es einfach jetzt
aktuell noch nicht durchführbar das
spiegelt auch das wider was viele hier
in der community schreiben ich kann ein
paar mal zitieren da warten viele
userinnen und user tatsächlich auf den
termin zum beispiel clara die schreibt
über youtube weder beim ins zentrum noch
beim hausarzt ist derzeit einen termin
zu bekommen prio gruppe zwei
beziehungsweise drei irgendwie sehr
ernüchternd blei ente schreibt auch über
youtube ich versuche seit wochen einen
termin zu bekommen auf der website zur
terminvereinbarung ist dauernd die es
dauernd überlastet und auch auf der
hotline kommt man nicht durch das
bezieht sich auf die impfzentren das
natürlich noch mal eine andere situation
als jetzt beim hausarzt
aber die frage ist natürlich herbeck wie
geht man damit um dass auf der einen
seite wie wir sehen so viele noch nicht
geimpft sind
wie wir gerade schon gehört haben und
viele jetzt aber das gefühl haben die im
trio regierung soll perspektivisch im
juni aufgehoben werden einige
bundesländer machen das schon jetzt dann
rufe ich an und dann möchte ich aber
auch bitte jetzt schnell geimpft werden
sie können anrufen sie können versuchen
schnell einen termin auszumachen
meine kollegin hat gerade angesprochen
wir machen das identisch unsere liste
ist soweit ich weiß über 30 din a4
seiten voll dies auch nicht abgearbeitet
der wesentliche faktor in diesem system
sind zweierlei zum einen die zeit in den
praxen dass es endlich und das andere
ist der nicht in ausreichender menge
vorhanden der impfstoff termine können
sie machen wie sie wollen wenn sie
nichts haben weil sie verändern können
nutzt das hier alles nix machen sie der
politik dem vorwurf ja letztlich schon
ich denke dass die art und weise wie wir
angefangen haben diese impfkampagne zu
planen
eu-weit nicht gerade optimal gelaufen
ist das hat sich ja mittlerweile
herumgesprochen dass da doch grobe
fehler gemacht worden sind
jetzt sind die hausärzte seite etwa fünf
wochen mit in der impfkampagne drin und
man merkt dann den jetzt doch rapide
steigenden ärzte im wohn und jetzt
demnächst zwei impfungen dass wir sehr
erfolgreich gekämpft haben
nichtsdestotrotz ist sind die
hausarztpraxen immer noch in der
situation dass sie einen impfstoffmangel
haben wir können nicht mehr verkaufen
wie das was wir bekommen und zum teil
ist das sehr ernüchternd was sie
bestellen und das dann tatsächlich am
ende dieser woche oder der nächsten
woche geliefert wird die struktur ist
leider sehr kompliziert sie kriegen 6er
oder zähne weil es also kleine flaschen
wo sechs impfdosen oder zehn impfdosen
drin sind bestellen die am dienstag
werden donnerstagabend informiert wie
viel von ihren bestellungen wirklich
geliefert werden das ganze aufgeteilt
nach erst- und zweite impfung und wenn
sie glück haben kommt bekommt der
impfstoff am montagabend der form
geliefert angebracht und erst dann
können sie sagen wir können die
impfungen fertig machen die kollegen
angesprochen
wir haben das problem einfach zu wenig
impfstoff und letztlich auch die praxen
sind irgendwo am ende der kapazität das
ganze zu steuern
frau doktor cook hier der blick in die
community zeigt die leute sind wirklich
sauer
sie wollen sich impfen lassen aber sie
kriegen keine termine aufgrund der
problematik die herr beck gerade
angesprochen hat wie ist denn die
stimmung bei ihnen in der praxis was
müssen sie sich da anhören
also im großen und ganzen ist das schon
alles noch sehr respektvoll aber es gibt
durchaus zu den einen oder anderen
patzer sage ich mal also werden sehr
häufig angerufen und dann kann der ton
sich verschärfen dann wird gefragt warum
wir es nicht hinkriegen einen termin zu
machen zum beispiel
dabei hat das ja nichts mit nicht wollen
zu tun sondern eben einfach mit nicht
können also man kann eben kein impfstoff
herzaubern und der ton ich muss sagen in
der praxis ist er wirklich noch gut und
in ordnung bis auf einzelfälle
ich arbeite aber noch im impfzentrum und
da ist es durchaus schon vorgekommen
dass leute aggressiv werden oder
begleitpersonen dabei haben die dann
geimpft werden sollen
dann wird sich auch schon mal aufgebaut
oder gegen die kabinenwand geschlagen
wenn man eben sagt wir können hier
nichts machen die zentrale die termine
werden dezentral vergeben
wir können ihnen jetzt hier kein
impfstoff anbieten
und da kippt die stimmung schneller in
der praxis wo man sich kennt und
vertraut ist ist es leichter sie sind
auch auf twitter unter anderem unterwegs
sind dort vertreten als schwester frau
doktor und wir haben einen tweet
rausgesucht von ihnen der unseld wie bei
all dem was so schief läuft
was in der uns ein bisschen ein bisschen
fröhlich gestimmt hat ich hoffe man kann
ihn hier sehen sie haben gezeigt wie die
patienten für die patienten beim impfen
die glücklichen die denn dann impftermin
haben das reagieren wenn sie sagen dass
man den arm bitte locker lassen soll
können sie kurz erklären was sie zu
diesem typ veranlasst hat das sind ist
einfach so einen tag wieder im
impfzentrum gewesen bei dem ich glaube
ich 80 mal gesagt habe mit den am ganz
locker lassen und das wird er aber erst
mal hier auf dieser höhe gehoben und
dann sagt nein bitte noch ein bisschen
lockerer lassen dann ist er essen fiel
am ende beim dritten ansprechen bleibt
er dann unten hängen also ich bin
inzwischen dazu übergegangen zu sagen
bitte einfach den arm ganz locker
henkel hatte wie so ein waschlappen dann
funktioniert normalerweise besser aber
die diese immer wieder sich
wiederholende situation die war einfach
sehr amüsant und dann habe ich
angefangen haben diesen schritt zu
basteln aber das eigentlich interessant
weil impfen ist ja was was man
eigentlich kennt aber in der situation
gerade im impfzentrum und wir zeigen
auch gleich noch mal einem stück wie es
in den impfzentren im moment aussieht
sind die leute natürlich besonders
angespannt weil das seine situation ist
die man so noch nicht erlebt hat in
diesem setting in diesem umfeld können
sie das nachvollziehen
ja natürlich also es gibt auch wirklich
viele menschen die total nervös sind
wenn sie dann zu uns in die kabine
kommen
man würde ja vorher durch mehrere
stationen die anmeldung und dann die
kontrolle der dokumente geschleust und
im wartebereich sitzen bis man dann zu
uns gekommen ist ist vielleicht dann
doch schon einige zeit vergangen wobei
die organisation wirklich gut ist und
das eigentlich relativ schnell geht aber
dann weiß man nicht so ganz was auf
einen zukommt und ich habe auch wirklich
schon erlebt dass impflinge wie man so
schön sagt
tränen vergossen haben weil sie endlich
geimpft worden sind und ich wirklich
gefreut haben also da gibt es schöne
situationen aber die anspannung die kann
ich nachvollziehen wenn man denn wenn
wir auch wie wir gerade unseren titel
nochmal eingeblendet haben glückssache
impftermin wenn man denn das glück hatte
einen impftermin zu bekommen und wie
schwierig das im moment ist und wie
schwer das vielleicht jetzt auch noch
durch die aktuellen im priorisierung
aufgaben sein wird das hat jana becker
zusammengefasst in kölner impfzentrum
können sich aktuell nur menschen impfen
lassen
die in eine der drei priorisierung
gruppen fallen tina dietze arbeitet im
maklerbüro hat für kundenkontakt so
hatten die kölnerin und ihr mann heute
die chance moderner verabreicht zu
bekommen bin ich schon sehr froh dass
wir ihn bekommen haben weil
wahrscheinlich wird es ein schwieriger
werdenden termin zu bekommen noch wird
in den impfzentren bundesweit streng
nach priorisierung 's gruppen geimpft
doch schon jetzt können in köln nur halb
so viele menschen geimpft werden wie es
die möglichkeiten im impfzentrum
eigentlich hergeben würden der mangel an
impfstoff macht nicht nur den
organisatoren im impfzentrum sorgen dass
auch für die hausarztpraxen zu wenig
impfstoff vorhanden
stellt sie alle vor herausforderungen
insbesondere in hinblick auf eine
aufhebung der priorisierung befürchten
dass wir da relativ viel ansturm in den
praxen kriegen die jetzt schon sehr
stark belastet sind wir hoffen dass wir
wenigstens den impfstoff so vollständig
bekommen das wird tatsächlich alles
machen können um so viele leute wie
möglich so schnell wie möglich impfen zu
können
neben der frage nach den im kapazitäten
wird der ethikrat auch
gerechtigkeitsfragen in den raum wenn
man vorzeitig die priorisierung aufs
laufen lässt das heißt bevor die
priorisierten gruppen alle das berühmte
angebot bekommen haben dann heißt das
natürlich dass die risikogruppen mit
mehr menschen um impftermine
konkurrieren
und das sehe ich durchaus kritisch dass
die terminvergabe zur krone impfung ab
dem siebten juni für alle geöffnet sein
soll bedeutet jedoch keinesfalls dass
jederzeit nach einen impftermin erhalten
wird es handelt sich lediglich um einen
impfangebot herr becker blicken wir mal
wieder in ihre praxis short lisa just
myself fragt über youtube oder sagte
impfzentren sind logistische
meisterwerke ich frage mich wie
hausärzte sowas wuppen sollen neben den
normalen patienten wie wollen sie das
und wie priorisieren sie denn im moment
ich weiß nicht genau ob herr beck uns
hören oder sehen kann
ich würde sagen im moment sieht es nicht
so aus ich hoffe kann uns hören und ist
gleich wieder bei uns und so lange
machen wir weiter mit frau kuckuck die
frage an sie wie priorisieren sie denn
im moment sie müssen ja jetzt die
entscheidungen treffen sie haben immer
noch priorisierung gruppe 2 und 3 und
sie haben perspektivisch in hessen auch
die priorisierung aufhebt oder
spätestens im juni wenn das dann
bundesweit so sein soll dass sie auch
entscheiden müssen aufgrund einer sehr
langen warteliste würde ich mutmaßen wie
nehme ich denn jetzt als erstes dran wie
entscheiden sie dass man aktuell ist es
noch relativ einfach weil wir ja schon
vor wochen diese listen angelegt haben
und immer noch patienten auf uns
zukommen und sagen ich möchte bitte auf
die liste aufgenommen
werden und wir kennen unsere patienten
ja sehr gut also wir wissen um die
vorerkrankungen und um das risiko wissen
deswegen ob es jetzt wichtig ist für
wenn es wichtig ist eine impfung zu
bekommen und wer vielleicht noch etwas
länger warten könnte
daran ändert sich jetzt auch erstmal
nichts auch wenn die priorisierung
aufgehoben wird weil eben diese
patienten die vor erkrankt sind
natürlich erst mal an der reihe sein
müssen und nicht die ganz jungen und
gesunden auch wenn man da immer in so
einer art zwickmühle ist weil gerade die
jungen patienten hier häufig mitten im
berufsleben stehen viele kontakte haben
familie kinder und die müssen geschützt
sein
nichtsdestotrotz stehen wir vor dem
dilemma dass es unfair wäre jetzt ich
sage mal alle zu impfen die eben möchten
oder wer einfach schneller ist wer
vielleicht schnell in die praxis kommen
kann
als jemand der nicht so mobil ist nicht
so gut zu fuß ist und etwas warten muss
auf den termin da sind uns ein bisschen
die hände gebunden also wir müssen
natürlich dann irgendwie erst mal die
liste abarbeiten
wir haben hier eine frage von ilona
houben die sagt mein hausarzt impfen
überhaupt nicht was macht man denn in
dem fall also kennen sie ärztin und
ärzte die sich entschieden haben sorry
aber das übersteigt meine kapazität das
kann ich gar nicht und was mache ich
denn dann als patient wenn mein hausarzt
das nicht macht und noch eine frage was
mache ich wenn ich keinen hausarzt habe
also ich persönlich kenne jetzt keine
praxis die nicht mithilft
aber da gibt es sicherlich einige den
die organisation vielleicht für eine
kleine praxis zu viel isst was ich
durchaus auch verstehen kann weil der
organisationsaufwand enorm ist wenn man
keinen hausarzt hat oder kein termin
beim hausarzt bekommt dann muss man sich
über die impfzentren melden das geht
über die einzelnen 61 17
auch da das erlebe ich auch in den
impfzentren häufig dass gerade junge
leute sagen die anderen doch länger
gewartet bis sie dann einen termin
bekommen haben die können sich auch über
die so genannten im rücken ja melden
also das sind ja große zentren
die astra zenica für impfen was ohne
priorisierung verimpft werden darf
allerdings noch ärztliche aufklärung bei
menschen unter 60 jahren und eben jeder
der über 60 ist der darf diesen
impfstoff bekommen und von daher gibt es
da noch die möglichkeit sich dort
anzumelden inzwischen gibt es wohl auf
einige start ups die sich mit also die
anbieten übrig gebliebene impfdosen von
praxen zu organisieren dass praxen sich
dort anmelden dürfen wenn doch etwas
übrig geblieben ist und dann die
impfwilligen schnell angerufen werden da
muss man praxis für registrieren
wir gucken gleich im weiteren verlauf
des streams auch noch mal welche portale
es gibt welche vor und nachteile es gibt
dann auch die innbrücke werden wir uns
dann nochmal genauer angucken
ist es ihrer meinung nach sinnvoll
mehrere eisen im feuer zu haben also
registrieren beim ins zentrum warteliste
beim hausarzt und möglicherweise auch
beim facharzt denn inzwischen können ja
auch hno-ärzte gynäkologen orthopäden
impfen was raten sie da also wenn man
mehr gleich fährt dann kann ich nur
darum bitten dann die überzähligen
termine die eben nicht gebraucht werden
fristgerecht abzusagen weil sonst wird
der impfstoff verworfen und das ist eine
katastrophe in der jetzigen situation
das gibt es durchaus dass patienten sich
bei uns anmelden und im impfzentrum
anmelden
ich finde das jetzt auch nicht
verwerflich weil man ja gerne schnellen
termin haben möchte aber dann eben mit
der prämisse den termin den man nicht
benötigt rechtzeitig abzusagen
noch ne frage macht es einen unterschied
ob man gesetzlich versichert ist oder
privat
nein das ist eine ganz klare antwort die
die frage liegt nämlich nahe weil man ja
oft auch erlebt wenn man beim arzt
anruft und sagt ich möchte gerne ein
termin und dann sagt man man ist privat
versichert und dann geht es mit dem
termin plötzlich ganz schnell wenn man
gesetzlich versichert ist dann dauert es
ein paar wochen da gibt es in dem fall
keinen unterschied könnte ihnen jetzt
auch überhaupt nicht sagen wer von
meine patienten privat ist heftig
versichert ist es gibt habe ich gelesen
verschiedene praxen die eine so genannte
impfberatung anbieten und dafür wenn ich
das richtig gelesen habe auch ganz gut
vergütet werden ist das geldmacherei
muss man da vorsichtig sein wenn man bei
einem arzt sich meldet und der sah der
sie können kommen aber sie brauchen
vorher neben beratungen termin dafür
dass ehrlich gesagt wäre ich das zum
ersten mal das finde ich ganz finde ich
etwas erschreckend irgendwie weil das ja
auch zu unserem jetzt zu unserer
jetzigen situation und aufgabe dazu
gehört dass wir beraten müssen das ist
ja tatsächlich das was es momentan auch
ein bisschen ja den arbeitsalltag
vollmacht weil wir ganz viele telefonate
führen müssen impfberatung parallel
machen zusätzlich zu den impfungen die
man eben also wir machen das an zwei
tagen in der woche nachmittags
zusätzlich aber ohne die impfberatung
kommt man ja vielleicht auch nicht
richtig empfunden man muss ja auch seine
patienten gut beraten und das finde ich
schon tatsächlich verwerflich wenn man
dafür viel geld verlangt auch wenn ich
in gewisser weise nachvollziehen kann
dass man sagt okay der ganze aufwand das
hat viele überstunden das kostet viel
geld
der regelbetrieb ist eingeschränkt ich
muss das geld irgendwie wieder reinholen
ich persönlich finde es nicht in ordnung
gucken wir noch mal auf die
priorisierung barrymore schreibt über
youtube ich finde dass zuerst alle prior
gruppen durchgeimpft werden sollen und
an dieser stelle welcome back armin beck
schön dass die leitung wieder da ist
schön dass sie uns wieder hören und
sehen könnte weg genau also die frage
nach der priorisierung diese userin sagt
ich finde dass zuerst alle brio gruppen
durch geimpft werden sollen und erst
dann alle anderen sonst hätte man es
gleich alle für freigeben können dazu
hören wir uns den nordrhein
westfälischen gesundheitsminister karl
josef laumann an der sich auch zur
priorisierung freigabe noch mal geäußert
hat hatte die provision wegfällt dann
ist es ganz einfach so dass natürlich
die der impfstoff der da ist es
man rein theoretisch für alle zugänglich
ist so ich gehe davon aus dass viele
hausärztinnen und hausärzte weiterhin
diejenigen impfen dies am notwendigsten
haben auch von ihrer ärztlichen ethik
her aber generell heißt aufhebung der
priorisierung das ist auch dann wenn
freie termine da sind eben wer zuerst
kommt mahlt zuerst also wenn sich
herausstellen sollte dass es
bevölkerungsgruppen gibt die keinen
guten zugang zum niedergelassenen system
haben das wir unter umständen den
impfzentren dann solche gruppen auch mal
einen ins angebot machen
okay wir sehen also es ist eine frage
der priorisierung aber auch eine frage
dessen welche impfstoffe denn überhaupt
da sind ein user fragt astrazeneca haben
aber eine ärzte haben aber einige ärzte
übrig oder also reden wir über alle
impfstoffe oder die berühmten besseren
oder schlechteren impfstoff herbeck wie
erleben sie das sagen die leute die ja
wir möchten gerne bei ihnen geimpft
werden aber bitte nicht mit astrazeneca
ja so was kommt vor das ist kollegin hat
vorhin gesagt die gespräche der
aufklärung finden ja sozusagen auch wir
haben der normalen sprechzeit statt das
heißt
in einer normalen beratung in der
normalen untersuchung kenne ich fragte
ich keinen fall mehr der nicht die frage
stellt und wie funktioniert es mit der
impfung das ist faktisch schon standard
und es gibt tatsächlich menschen die
dann entsprechend des alters in die
gruppen astrazeneca hinein fallen
könnten und denen wir das alle anbieten
und dann sagen das möchten aber nicht
hört dann ist es also wie erleben sie
das fragt ja ähnlich also im impfzentrum
tatsächlich noch ein bisschen schlimmer
hatte ich ja schon angedeutet dass da
der ton manchmal ein bisschen ruppiger
ist in der praxis erklärt sich das meist
schon vorab wenn man das impfangebot
macht und die termine versucht er unter
zu bringen
dass es dann dass gefragt und welchen
impfstoff bekäme ich denn dann wird es
gesagt hat okay wunderbar ich krieg den
guten impfstoff oder es heißt ja nee den
anderen den möchte ich aber nicht
oft kann man ja auch mit viel aufklärung
da dann doch zum ja die die sorgen
nehmen
aber das ist eigentlich schon häufig
dass patienten sagen also ich möchte
eigentlich lieber den impfstoff und
nicht in anderen wie ist das denn
eigentlich wenn sie gut oder schlecht
unsinnig ist
das wollte ich sie das wollte ich schon
gezuckt als ich die frage vorgelesen
habe das jetzt bestimmt jemand von ihnen
sagen wird gute oder schlechte
impfstoffe können wir so gar nicht
unterscheiden können sie das noch mal
erklären warum es aus ihrer sicht keine
guten und schlechten in derendorf
ergeben so viel zeit muss sein
letztlich sind es alles letzte salz sind
das alles immer zugelassene impfstoffe
und unabhängig davon gibt es dann noch
regelungen landes internen welche in
gruppen oder welche patientengruppen für
den einen oder anderen als als
geeigneter dienen wie wir umgekehrt das
ist insgesamt in deutschland ein
besonderes problem weil man angefangen
hat den astra zeneca impfstoff zunächst
nur für menschen unter 60 hauptsächlich
dadurch die kolleginnen kollegen unserer
gruppe beziehungsweise unsere
angestellten die dann wie immer
ansehen oder die klinikmitarbeiter dann
wurde das wieder umgedreht dann war es
der über 60 und dann er nur männer also
es also ein bisschen hin und her und
damit hat man sozusagen die leute sehr
verunsichert das ist so wie bei der
bundesliga es gibt 82 millionen
bundestrainer und so viel im
spezialisten gibt es jetzt mittlerweile
auch jeder hat so seine meinung
letztlich sind alle impfstoffe
zugelassen und alle impfstoffe schützen
sehr sehr gut gegen eine schwere gruppe
die infektion und letztlich geht es
genau darum 1 1 ein kleiner infekt einer
kurve die infektion im sinne eines
grippalen infektes ist völlig egal und
spielt überhaupt keine rolle was wichtig
ist dass wir die leute nicht
hospitalisierten müssen und nicht diese
schlimme szenen die sie alle kennen aus
den intensivstationen habt und dagegen
helfen alle diese impfstoffe sehr gut
und das machen wir wahrscheinlich alle
in den praxen gleich wir versuchen die
leute aufzuklären
auch männer oder frauen unter der 60
die bereit sind sich mit dem astra
zeneca impfstoff impfen zu lassen wenn
sie damit einverstanden sind und über
die risiken aufgeklärt sind findet das
jetzt in den letzten tagen immer
vermehrt statt weil dieser impfstoff ein
bisschen einfacher handhabbar ist wie
der bayernlb impfstoff der ja in 120
stunden zumindestens stand jetzt 120
stunden verimpft werden muss wir sehen
wir haben hier tatsächlich auch
wir haben im skeptiker im chat das
erleben wir auch dass wir in der
community viele leute sagen die haben
impfen
nein danke das ist aber wiederum ein
thema was wir heute hier nicht
besprechen wollen und werden viele
allerdings sind auch unglaublich dankbar
und sagen zum glück bin ich geimpft und
zum glück ging's so schnell die fälle
gibt es tatsächlich auch markus müller
schreibt über youtube freitag angerufen
und montag im termin beim hausarzt
bekommen da hat also schnell
funktioniert und eine sache die mich
jetzt noch interessiert ist bavaria wars
schreibt über youtube heute mit der
ersten astrazeneca dosis versorgt worden
und das ohne priorität gruppe ich kann
nur jedem empfehlen pro aktiv zu werden
habe meinen termin über ebay
kleinanzeigen bekommen haben sie das
schon mal gehört und können sie sie
erklären wie das funktioniert kann ich
mir nicht erklären dass letztlich alles
funktioniert und der der patient oder
der mitbürger ist geändert worden dann
hat der rechnung funktioniert egal wer
sich das da so einfallen lässt
die priorisierung von astrazeneca ist ja
in einigen bundesländern schon viel
länger aufgehoben auch in hessen und
damit können wir da auch bisher etwas
lockerer umgehen das heißt auch leute
die freiwilligen proaktiv kommen ich
würde mich dann gerne mit impfen lassen
wir hätten damit dann entsprechend der
gruppe auch geimpft die kv hessen hat ja
da auch vor kurzem sein
werbeangebot losgetreten im sinne von
urlaubs impfungen jetzt lassen sich mit
astrazeneca kämpfen
das scheint großen widerhall gefunden zu
haben das heißt einige menschen die er
so ein bisschen skeptisch waren haben
sich mit aufklärung dann mit diesem
stoff inseln lassen und meine gesamte
praxis ich selber sind ebenfalls mit
astrazeneca geimpft und außerdem den
unter umständen kleinen impfreaktionen
mit ein bisschen lieber kollege war
tatsächlich zwei tage fieber krank und
der große rest der praxis hat er gar nix
den ging es um allen guten wir sind
mittlerweile alle durchgemacht und haben
damit wirklich kein großes problem also
diese nebenwirkung situation ist
beschrieben sie ist vorhanden und aus
die leute aufklären und mittlerweile
wissen wir auch wie weiter umgehen
sollen das heißt die die die
tatsächlichen todesfälle sind
aufgetreten und sieht sehr traurig aber
die sind mittlerweile wenn man sich
vernünftig verhält und auf die risiken
achtet und die symptome achtet auch gut
beherrschbar ist dieser stoff sehr gut
fenster und es hat keinen sinn den nicht
zu verhindern weil
der ist er im kühlschrank gelagert und
nicht verimpft werden kann was man aus
einigen impfzentren gehört oder auch in
einigen arztpraxen wird ist einfach
quatsch das medikament wirkt gut hilft
gut und wächst sehr schnell von daher
bitte wer möchte sollte sich an seinen
hausarzt so der seinen verrat zu wenden
und sollen sich hin zu lassen quatsch
entschuldigung herr chocabeck eine frage
an sie noch zum schluss ist ihre praxis
an ein system angeschlossen was die
terminvergabe regelt und auch an ein
system angeschlossen was möglicherweise
menschen die möglichkeit gibt sich bei
ihnen impfen zu lassen wenn bei ihnen
was übrig bleibt oder machen sie das
nicht also ein internes also im internet
system haben sich angeschlossen bisher
nicht weil wir versuchen mir sind ja
immer noch in der situation stand jetzt
dass wir insbesondere die prio zwei
leute prior 1 ist fertig bringt zwei
leute gibt es noch ein paar dass wir die
wirklich abarbeiten und liste fertig
abarbeiten damit kann man im internet
buchen und ich machen wir haben uns
allerdings schon mit dem thema befasst
und mit der fragestellung es kommen
jetzt wirklich sehr sehr viele anfragen
ist das ein thema das wir wahrscheinlich
in den nächsten wochen umsetzen werden
nicht mehr sehen ob das technisch
funktioniert weil das ist nicht
vollständig trivial unsere it-systeme
sind üblicherweise nicht direkt in der
lage solche systeme zu übernehmen weil
wir eigentlich
nicht nur online sondern offline
arbeiten oder mitgeteilten systemen
es gibt anbieter die das ganze web
basiert machen das nicht mal sehen wie
gut und wie schlecht das ganze ist
bisher machen sie was wirklich
telefonisch oder persönlich die
patienten konnten melden sich an sagen
sie hätten gern auf würden auf die liste
würden gerne geimpft werden und dann
schauen wir dass wir die entsprechenden
blöcke zusammen kriegen also sechs oder
zehn jahre und tieren einladen und dann
durch schimpfen freund hat was die
kolleginnen wird gesagt hat die
dankbarkeit ist irre also wenn sie die
erste und zweite in bogen den patienten
sehen da sehen sie selten in arztpraxen
glückliche menschen da sehen die echt
glückliche menschen
vielen dank herr beck fragt wie es das
bei ihnen
mit welchem system oder arbeiten sie
überhaupt schon mit dem system so
ähnlich wie das in angedacht ist bayern
weg oder wie machen sie das nur mit dem
telefon
es ist genauso wie herr beck das gesagt
hat wir haben unsere listen wir
telefonieren die patienten durch schauen
dass wir immer so viele patienten
zusammen gekommen an einem nachmittag
also machen sie an zwei nachmittagen in
der woche dass man die die welt
sozusagen man kann ja sechs oder zehn
dosen zum teil mit der richtigen technik
auch mehr rausziehen dass wir die leute
dann eben zusammengekommen und online
nein haben wir uns noch nicht damit
beschäftigt dann ganz kurz zum abschluss
noch an sie die frage frau coco die
anderen die gar keine corona impfung
haben wollen sondern einfach nur zum
hausarzt gehen wollen weil sie ein
problem haben mit dem sie normalerweise
immer zum hausarzt gegangen sind haben
sie überhaupt noch zeit für die ja das
muss ja natürlich sein also wenn das ist
immer noch der großteil der des
alltagsgeschäfts aber oft ist es eben so
dass jemand kommt mit einem alltäglichen
problemen sei es rückenschmerzen und
dann kommt im nachgang jetzt hätte ich
aber doch noch mal die frage zur impfung
und dann schiebt man auch schnell so die
impfberatung hinter
[Gelächter]
alles klar dann sage ich ganz herzlichen
dank doktor ulrike krug und herr beck
vielen dank dass sie heute abend mit in
der sendung waren und uns an ihrem
hausarzt praxis alltag haben teilhaben
lassen vielen dank und wir werfen den
blick deshalb habe ich auch die frage
nach dem system gestellt welche
möglichkeiten es denn im moment
überhaupt gibt
sowohl bei den hausärzten über
verschiedene plattformen als auch über
die impfzentren sich für einen
impftermin registrieren zu lassen julia
viegener hat sich einen überblick
verschafft schlange stehen für die
impfung die spritze gegen das corona
virus ist begehrt zum termin führen
viele wege
wer berechtigt ist kann sich beim im
zentrum registrieren die terminvergabe
ist ländersache und läuft über online
plattformen und telefonisch teilweise
gibt es auch wartelisten um
übriggebliebene dosen an impfwillige zu
verteilen
der zweite weg die arztpraxis hier im
nicht nur hausärztinnen und hausärzte
sondern auch fachpraxen wie kinder und
hno ärztin gynäkologen und urologen wer
sich meldet kommt auf die warteliste
auch in den praxen gilt die
priorisierung nun aber wird die
reihenfolge in immer mehr bundesländern
aufgehoben und am 17 juni
deutschlandweit dann starten übrigens
auch die betriebs ärztinnen und ärzte
sowie privatpraxen regulär mit den
impfungen wo es mit dem termin am
schnellsten klappt hängt von sehr vielen
faktoren ab und das deshalb von fall zu
fall unterschiedlich private online
plattform wollen helfen eine spritze zu
ergattern
sie vermitteln wenn termine kurzfristig
frei werden oder abends noch impfstoff
übrig ist
der weg zum impftermin gerade für die
jüngeren gehört zur zeit noch etwas
glück dazu
und damit sind wir bei der frage wie
föderalist deutschland vor der frage
nach digitaler vergabe von impftermin
und damit sind wir bei lorenz matzat von
algorithmen watch eine gemeinnützige
organisation die sich anschaut welche
auswirkungen automatisierte
entscheidungsfindung systeme auf unsere
gesellschaft haben
herr matzat welche unterschiedlichen
nach ländern aufgedröselt möglichkeiten
gibt es denn und wie gut oder wie
schlecht ist das ja guten abend ich kann
jetzt nicht für alle 16 bundesländer das
aufzählen ich kann drei beispiele nennen
in berlin ist das eine plattform die von
einem französischen konzern der
normalerweise praxen mit einer software
versorgt mit der man termine machen kann
vermitteln kann in bayern wurden sie
extra entwickelte system und da wird ein
bisschen gewürfelt weil das bei mir geht
er noch mal besprechen und
schleswig-holstein beispielsweise werden
das ist ein großer anbieter eigentlich
für veranstaltungstermine der wurde
sozusagen beauftragt eine lösung zu
entwickeln und zu betreiben und die
problematik dabei merkt man ja schon es
gibt in jedem bundesland eine andere
lösung oder in den meisten und bei den
mengen von denen wir regen an der mini
vergeben werden komme neben
automatisierte entscheidung
wahrscheinlich immer wieder ein spiel
das ist das kann vom zufall abhängen bis
geben dass bestimmte werte und das sogar
des chors vergeben werden also jetzt
jemand aufgrund seiner seines berufs
oder seines alters wegen dann vorzug
wird oder nicht
das grundsatzproblem was wir als
organisation hat angreifen jetzt mal die
frage der nachvollziehbarkeit und
transparenz funktioniert das möglichst
fair
wie wird das getan lässt sich das
überprüften nachvollziehen auf den
einzelnen
und so weiter es gibt wenn ich die noch
hinzufügen darf tatsächlich bei der
kreisverwaltung borken haben wir
gefundene nordrhein westfalen ein
eigenes vergabesystem dass dort bei
einem im landkreis ansässigen namhaften
software unternehmen in auftrag gegeben
worden ist und ich weiß nicht ob es
zufall ist dass dieser landkreis borken
den wir gerade genannt haben der
wahlkreis von bundesgesundheitsminister
jens spahn ist wenn sie sich angucken
was da gerade passiert auf welchen
ebenen welche möglichkeiten es da gibt
der maz hat wie groß ist ihr entsetzen
darüber dass man sich diese frage nicht
frühzeitig gestellt hat und ein
transparentes funktionierendes gutes
system aufgelegt hat was diese sachen
zentral steuern kann
mein entsetzen hält sich in grenzen weil
ich schon seit über zehn jahren mir die
digitalisierung seien verwaltung die
nicht stattfindet digitalisierung
zahlbach verwaltungen anschauen oder
betrachte beobachte begleite und das
dabei jetzt gerade das unvermögen
wirklich sichtbar wird ist ja auch ein
bildungssystem zum beispiel zu sehen wie
viel zeit verloren worden ist weil hier
eingehender welt leben wo viele personen
jahren mobiles internet-gerät wie in der
tasche haben und erreichbar wären und
sich eigentlich auf diese doch schon
fast magische infrastruktur hätte man
ersetzen können um so etwas zu
organisieren und gesehen das ist quasi
immer noch eben per telefon viel
passieren muss und da ist eben das nicht
winkel sagt wenn die eine ärzten ja auch
schon angesprochen das thema fairness
noch ein bisschen wie wird mit leuten
umgegangen wie wir vielleicht technisch
nicht mehr so ganz vorne dabei sind
haben die niemanden haben der ihnen
assistiert oder hilft dabei den termin
zu machen und fallen wahrscheinlich kann
bei solchen system muss darum geht
möglichst schnell als erster da zu sein
hinten runter und daraus mich nicht
erstaunt oder erschreckt sondern eher
wundert ist dass wir eigentlich ihre
organisationen haben die sowas
frühzeitig hätten
können wir haben die ständige
impfkommission wir haben den ethikrat
wir haben eigentlich einrichtungen die
digitale lösungen liefern sollten oder
auch bewerten können
da sozusagen seit vergangenem sommer
seit dem jahr spätestens klar ist dass
eine impfung gemacht werden müssen und
zwar für 60 millionen euro oder mehr
dass da auch mal überhaupt niemand sich
mal sachen müssen darüber mal sprechen
und konzepte entwickeln wenn wir über
fairness sprechen können wir das mal
ganz konkret machen also angenommen wir
haben ein unternehmen was jetzt weil es
systemrelevantes in die priorisierung
gruppe 3 feld und ab einem bestimmten
tag können sich alle mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter dieses unternehmens
registrieren lassen über die impfzentren
und die tun das und es gibt kolleginnen
und kollegen die bekommen innerhalb von
zwei tagen einen impftermin und es gibt
kolleginnen und kollegen die warten drei
wochen auf einen impftermin und hören
gar nichts wie kann das sein und nach
welchen algorithmen entscheiden
diese systeme werden jetzt das glück hat
in dem termin zu bekommen und wer nicht
also da kannst natürlich verschiedene
wurden begeben also es gibt sozusagen
ein grund ist schlecht gemachte software
die einfach nicht durchdacht ist wo
einfach vorher nicht drüber nachgedacht
wurde okay wir müssen jetzt pro tag
10.000 es termine vergeben
und das kann dazu führen dass leute eben
auch gleichzeitig versuchen das zu
bekommen das haben wir in berlin zum
beispiel dass man dort auf die webseite
kommt und dann mehr oder minder per
zufall wenn man glück hat zum richtigen
augenblick kommt ein termin nächste
woche angeboten bekommt oder erst in
fünf wochen
so aber es wird eben nicht darüber
aufgeklärt dass ich hier gerade per
zufall terminal- zugeschustert bekommen
und wenigstens das würde ich erwarten
weil ich ja natürlich davon ausgehe dass
ich hier oder einem system so gebaut
wird dass ich den nächstmöglichen termin
bekommen dass das nicht trivial ist bei
dieser großen menge ist ein anderes
thema andere algorithmen oder ein
algorithmus den soweit wir wissen in
bayern im einsatz ist das haben die
kolleginnen kollegen vom bayerischen
rundfunk zumindest anhand von indizien
julian erahnen können oder zeigen können
dass er offenbar dort bestimmte gruppen
sozusagen auf ihr alter noch ein er
würfelt sozusagen älter gemacht werden
und damit schneller eben in richtung
einer impfung kommen was der nachteil
dabei ist oder wer dabei in die röhre
guckt sind dann tatsächlich zum beispiel
80 jährige wie nicht ein aufschlag mehr
kriegen und dann von leuten überholt
werden die 79 sind und per zufall noch
20 jahre oben drauf geschlagen bekommen
also diese systeme sind in bayern
beispielsweise gesagt dann die
landesregierung mit der zeit ein
geheimnis wie das funktioniert damit
kein betrug organisiert wird was man
beliebtes argument ist um das nicht
offen zu legen
das heißt es abschließend zu sagen hier
müsste meiner meinung nach auf jeden
fall alle höchste transparenz an den tag
gelegt werden um vertrauen herzustellen
und was er vor allem verwundert ist dass
man die leute eben dass man die
technologie nicht nutzt den termin zum
beispiel einfach per zufall also per los
sozusagen zu übergeben und den leuten
einfach einen zukommen lässt sondern sie
müssen schnell warum kümmern so dass das
ja wie gesagt im zeitalter des digitalen
schon eine sehr altertümliche
herangehensweise nun haben ja noch nicht
alle bundesländer diese priorisierungen
geöffnet aber ab siebten juni soll das
bundesweit zu sein wenn es jetzt schon
glückssache ist ein impftermin zu
bekommen wie viel glück muss man dann
den ab siebter juni haben wenn sie eine
gute aussetzung einer guten hausarzt
haben und dass man auf 130 seiten einer
herr freund erwähnte stehen und haben
sich wahrscheinlich relativ bald glück
wenn sie niemanden haben der islam
gehäuft markt so einen termin zu
vereinbaren oder sie kein internet haben
oder sonst was haben sie wahrscheinlich
sind sie bald im rennen um die wir erst
mal die nächsten wochen monate nicht
dabei
ja also das ist tatsächlich das
vielleicht auch abhängig vom bundesland
würde unterschiedlicher qualität und
gute news sein ich weiß aus meiner
mutter
und 80 er hat im nordrhein westfalen
ihre impfung bekommen und die hat ihren
termin dadurch bekommen dass mein bruder
fünf stunden lang auch reload bedrückt
hat bei der vergabe website also das ist
wirklich je nach bundesland ein anderes
dürfte spielen sagt lorenz matzat von
algorithmen watch vielen dank dass sie
heute abend mit in unserer sendung waren
dankeschön wir sind gespannt wie es dann
in den nächsten wochen tatsächlich
laufen wird und zum abschluss der
sendung möchte ich gerne gerade noch mal
hier auf meinem monitor umschalten denn
es gibt tatsächlich zu der frage wie man
über ebay kleinanzeigen einen impftermin
bekommt einen artikel auf der zdf heute
hier vom 55
also noch nicht alt und der erklärt wie
tatsächlich ein allgemeinmediziner und
kardiologe aus ostwestfalen selbst den
weg gewählt hat über ebay kleinanzeigen
impftermine zu vergeben zitat es wäre
wahnsinn den zuverlässigen und wirksamen
impfstoff verkommen zu lassen in bezug
auf astra zeneca wir sehen also
kreativität hilft immer hilft immer auch
in diesem fall sowohl bei der frage wie
verteile ich den impfstoff als auch bei
der frage wie bekomme ich den impfstoff
und damit mache ich an dieser stelle
schluss und sage vielen herzlichen dank
heute abend fürs zuschauen und mitmachen
und für die vielen fragen und kommentare
die wir heute zu diesem thema bekommen
haben machen sie es gut schönen abend